I also want to thank all the people from
San Francisco and Seattle coming to my
show you guys sold those shows out and I
can I cannot be more appreciative also
on top of that I'd like to apologize
some people coming up to my show I had a
couple of new jokes I should get more
jokes out there but um what but what the
what the point of you guys coming to the
show is so we can be with each other and
exchange juices and energies what is it
called again fellowship fellowship and I
like to hug you
and a lot of people I met in San
Francisco there was a lot of good hugs I
do have a stalker out there in San
Francisco in San Diego Mike manager
keeps calling me there's this girl
that's stalking here she calls me 20
times a day I don't know how the [ __ ]
she got my cell phone she said give me
and getting me in touch of him now I he
I am Tiger belly weight that's what she
says I'm a part of it you know what's up
and I'm like wow that's not your only
stalker I think Gilbert George and I
intercept a lot of very similar messages
from very unstable people both male and
female like give me an example of one so
we have this guy who produced it
incessantly Facebook and Twitter
we used to probably get me on your show
get me on your show which some people do
on occasion yeah this person was so
insistent upon it that he would tweet as
like like 50 times a day
that's not stalker I think this person
right wants to get a untouchable and
then like use my skin as a jacket what
else has she done other than just
talking [ __ ] I don't know she's some of
the texts it's in the other room but
when she sends me texts my manager my
name this is my Korean name and then
half the messages in Korean which I
can't even read right and then a lot of
it is like sporadic and doesn't make any
sense like I am Tiger belly I need it
you know let me be inside it yeah I you
know have them call me now stuff like
that that I don't think that yeah your
your it sounds like you're the fix a
fixation of
somebody going through a very manic
psychotic breakdown and psychotic the
write down constantly no but my point is
is that if this person actually like
this person they're listening right now
I'm a mess I don't know what I'm doing
my back hurts my neck hurts right I I'm
confused
half the time when I wake up I don't
know what's going on should I fear for
my life like what if she thinks like
she's entitled to this throne is this a
throne I mean this red chair was like
what if she's like oh like I need to be
the co-host and then I end up getting
killed I need to be Bobby's girl would
you have her on the show after I die
that's the most ridiculous if that this
is the truth if that happened she comes
to the house right yeah with knives she
discovered at home she disguised as like
uber something he overheats I don't know
she gets in the house and then she's
like you're sleeping and she sticks 59
knives inside your vagina yeah and then
you bleed out yeah and then I get a calm
on the road I get a call some woman came
in and stabbed
kalila vagina to death I'd be like that
beautiful response yeah I think I'm so
sorry and then I would probably go into
like shock right and then I would
probably figure out how to get home
right away and then I would probably end
up you know going through obviously the
plea if we they catch the person or not
you don't sound very sad I am sad for
you yeah that's like a pretend like
because it's not I don't want him to
think I'm a suspect so I'm gonna do this
fake no that's not what it was
I'll do it again
mr. Lee I didn't say anything ever why
did your voice go on I don't know
that would give you a holiday suspect on
your if I started crying before let's
play that out go ahead why why are you
crying I was just about to my regular
voice no I was just about to tell your
girlfriend was gonna get her vagina oh
yeah yeah
so know what I would add come back and
they just listen okay and then I would
be completely weed you know the funeral
everything and I'd probably ended up
giving the animals away you know I would
call Quinn down goat you take it can you
please help me with Remy and go be and
the cats I'd say it Steve you can live
in my house but um
you have to take care of the cats for
the rest of their lives and then I would
probably just take all my money out of
all my bank accounts and get cash and I
would go into the desert and I would
[ __ ] drug out until I passed it like
overdosed that's exactly what I do
though you have to live no no I can't
live with it I would not be able to live
with it they would I would be in like in
the desert in some [ __ ] Shack just
with needle marks and that'd be die
I would feel like I would have died in
vain then well then you died in vain
like if you did not like continue to be
a happy person I will oh yeah you can't
move on with that I mean I want you to
be sad for like at least three years
okay Bobby gets stabbed in the penis 20
times cop well he's still alive though
you don't think I bleed to death or
bleed to death
oh so right now what's your life what's
your life my life I would mourn
[Music]
I wouldn't even be able you won't even
hear a sound cuz you know that kind of
cry we Oh like you're not breathing
because the air is out of your lungs
you're like and then like every every 30
seconds it comes out I would try to find
little pieces of his dick that I can
immortalize what and like well that's a
microscope or something because imagine
my dick it's already little right it's
like microscopic pieces you'd put them
together like it's a I would dedicate my
life to learning how to like sculpt
human meat and I would put it back
together I would like that act like
10,000 hours I would sit there like you
know it's only Collette her little like
dollhouse yeah yeah yeah sit there and I
would try to like gorilla glue it back
together interesting and then what would
you do with my dick intro now I would
like I would create like you know
unboxing Helena yeah yeah yeah I would
just create a shrine with you like a
little penis and I would offer it food
every day I would like give it a little
suck they're gonna worship his penis
like that and then what would happen and
then what after the with her dog from
yeah that was great and then I would do
I would you suck my go stick if I came
back on Hanukkah you would [ __ ] my god
still look sort of the same like if you
come back and you try to scare me and
[ __ ] you want to be able to what I would
do any guy that you [ __ ] saw after me
you'd scare him no but if he's [ __ ]
you I'm [ __ ] him like he'll be he'll
be [ __ ] you and you'd be like there's
something in my bottle
and it's my [ __ ] gun that's weird I
can't be a part of this oh my god you'll
never you'll never see you should have a
movie we should create a movie instead
of ghost dad yeah it was dick go stick
that speech on around porn yeah that
would be a hit yeah I would do that yeah
you would never see anybody I have a
feeling if I died in six months you'd
see somebody else six months six months
a year here no yeah fill me you do not
know me
you don't know my level of grief I I
grieve deeply you would [ __ ] though just
to get it out ya know I said I think
that I would probably enter like a
[ __ ] like a convent and probably like
become mute and never speak again or
something like gosh
I wouldn't [ __ ] either I believe that
you'd [ __ ] like two and a half hours
no way I think there's a very fine line
between grieving and like feeling
feeling grief and feeling horny I think
there's like some like I think I think
this I could possibly see that dangerous
we're in a dangerous territory guys
we're in a very dangerous area dangerous
but I could see six months from now like
unless you died and oh my god is so
dangerous seven months this is the only
scenario I think you said four years
right what I think you said four years
you have four years or four years from
now right
I mean my house I mean whatever I'm here
whatever right and then like you know
that lady that babysits her are animals
were a whack she makes she's a great
animal mom I wouldn't blame you yeah
yeah but she's like a you know she's a
nice lady
no I was talking to the other one that
we dropped him off that older like buff
one we had an older Buffy yeah we would
drop it off on a labret over there
older formosa drop off gobi when we go
on vacation we drop it off at that house
on Formosa oh oh yes yeah that militant
like seven year old lady I would get
like a [ __ ] from her he's like a
sheep but she also is like an ex like
marine or something no no you know those
competitive well be a bodybuilder like a
bodybuilder she's the [ __ ] thick neck
that's all oh that was good that's just
from her though I don't know
that's okay you know what I think that
we probably gave your stalker way too
much information and way too many grow
weird ideas yeah this lady just don't
don't do anything just stop if you love
Bobby if you love me stop I can keep
your distance keep the distance you know
I'm not I'm your friend
definitely don't kill me
[Music]